acting as caretakers of these Scoundrels
is beneath us oh please if they were
beneath you my R friend they'd all be
[Music]
dead keep in line
Odin continues to bring me new
friends how thoughtful the books I sent
do they not interest
you is that how I to Wi away eternity
reading I've done everything in my power
to make you comfortable Loki have
you does Odin share your
concern does
Thor it must be so inconvenient them
asking after me day and night you know
full well it was your actions that
brought you here my actions I was merely
giving truth to the lie that I've been
fed my entire life that I was born to be
a king a
king a true king admits his faults what
of the lives you took on earth a mere
handful compared to the number that Odin
has taken himself your father he's not
my
father then am I not your
mother
you're
not always so perceptive about everyone
but
yourself